[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit anna
zimmermann und christian sievers
guten abend hinein ein mann der reformen
im kreml ist von uns gegangen
wir trauern um einen der keinen kalten
krieg mehr wollte und wir denken dabei
natürlich an den aktuellen herrn in
moskau der gerade erst einen neuen
grausamen krieg angezettelt hat michael
gorbatschow ist tot er war der einzige
generalsekretär des zentralkomitees der
kommunistischen partei der sowjetunion
denen man bürgern ahnen konnte einer der
anders war und anders dachte als die
grauen apparatschiks vor ihm einer der
dermaßen große veränderungen für die
welt brachte das ihm dass manche in
seinem eigenen land nie verziehen haben
und der gleichzeitig für viele im westen
zum helden wurde zu gorbi nirgendwo ist
das sichtbarer als in berlin christhard
läpple
berlin am abend die russische fahne auf
der botschaft ist nicht auf halbmast vor
der moskauer vertretung unter den linden
sind blumen und botschaften jedoch nicht
für gorbatschow sondern für die ukraine
aber die menschen reagieren auf seinen
tod durch wert mit respekt und trauer
für mich ist er einer der besten
menschen weil er hat die menschen
zusammengebracht dadurch dass er den
fragen niedergerissen hat der nicht
gewesen wäre und so offen wer heute
immer noch dass einer der großen
staatsmänner des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts das heißt auch wenn ich
noch von einer anderen generation bin
ist auch mein leben trotzdem von ihm
geprägt wurden gorbatschow war ein
politiker mit herz und seele
auch die verbindungen zu seiner frau und
wenn er kam also das war quasi das
gegenteil von putin jeder meter auf dem
boulevard unter den linden kann eine
geschichte über gorbi erzielen so
nannten ihn nicht nur die berliner in
der wendezeit 89 sagte er ddr-staats-
und parteichef honecker einen
folgenreichen satz
geschichte schrieb
neuer passendes die deutsche post dhl
toni reagieren ich glaube gefahren
warten nur auf jene die nicht auf das
leben reagieren
daraus wurde das berühmte wer zu spät
kommt den bestraft das leben das hat
gorbatschow zwar nie so gesagt aber die
botschaft verstand jeder
[Musik]
es ist auch wirklich so dass mir viele
leute sagen ich weiß noch genau was das
damals bedeutet hat ich weiß was es für
mein eigenes leben bedeutet hat und ich
kann ihnen nur sagen als jemand der in
frankfurt oder geboren ist hier in
berlin seit über 20 jahren auch erleben
und gestalten darf ich bin michael
gorbatschow persönlich dankbar ab morgen
liegt im roten rathaus für den
ehrenbürger berlins ein kondolenzbuch
aus sein name ist untrennbar mit dem
fall der mauer und der vereinigung
verboten aber auch mit der idee eines
geeinten friedlichen europas er liebte
die menschen das spürte man wenn man ihm
begegnete er wollte wirklich frieden
abrüstung entspannung und seine große
vision war das gemeinsame haus europas
also europa mit russland zusammen auch
für ddr bürgerrechtler werner schulz ist
der tut gorbatschows ein großer verlust
aber er hofft für russland und dann
kommt plötzlich so ein hoffnungsträger
dann kommt plötzlich so eine
lichtgestalt wie gorbatschow und das
sagt mir es gibt wahrscheinlich immer
wieder so jemand der da kommen wird es
ist eine große nation und es wird einen
menschen geben der nach putin kommt es
wird einen nachfolger und geben und der
wird uns möglicherweise wieder die hand
reichen michael gorbatschow der visionär
der die welt veränderte und er weiß
selbst dürfte der mann dem die deutschen
so viel zu verdanken haben
am samstag soll es eine trauerfeier
geben für michail gorbatschow im haus
der gewerkschaften in moskau wo
traditionell die trauerfeiern
stattfanden für die staatschefs der
sowjetunion dass die spitze des
deutschen staats dabei ist wäre in
normalen zeiten
selbstverständlich aber wir leben nicht
in normalen zeiten und so konnte man von
olaf scholz heute vormittag diesen satz
hören
ich hoffe dass der russische staat in
seinen früheren staats und
regierungschefs die ehre erweist ihm
gebührt
ein friedensnobelpreisträger der zur
hassfigur wurde bei denen die alte
sowjetzeiten zurück wollen der nachruf
jetzt von christian kirsch
michael clg wird gorbatschow er war
weltbewegend
als alter mann auf dem pariser platz am
brandenburger tor hier sehe es anders
aus ohne ihn
anfang der 90er bricht er im kreml die
politisch tief gefrorene sowjetunion auf
ihr standen sich damals zwei mächtige
blöcke in europa gegenüber das war doch
ein pulverfass wenn uns das explodiert
wäre allein schon deshalb mussten wir
mit reformen beginnen
gorbatschow und die abrüstung
spektakuläre verträge mit den
us-amerikanern ganze klassen von
atomwaffen wurden wegverhandelt
gorbatschow und die wiedervereinigung
strickjacken diplomatie im kaukasus
ermöglicht das ende der deutschen
teilung
aber auch gorbatschow und der
wirtschaftliche zusammenbruch der
sowjetunion hunger armut oligarchen
korruption und gorbatschow um das ende
der sowjetunion ein referendum besiegelt
das schicksal des kolossalen staates der
untergang des roten riesen reiches von
gorbatschow nicht gewollt doch er trat
die dinge los wurde letztlich überrollt
von der geschichte
nur wenige russen mögen ihn der kreml
heute schmallippig
dann sicherlich wollte er glauben dass
der kalte krieg enden würde und eine
ewige romantische phase zwischen der
sowjetunion und dem kollektiven westen
beginne aber diese romantisierung
ist nicht eingetreten
wir wissen dass er in einer zeit
gestorben ist denn der nicht nur die
demokratie in russland
gescheitert ist und gerade deshalb
denken wir an michael gorbatschow und
wissen welche bedeutung er für die
entwicklung europas und auch unseres
landes in den letzten jahren hatte
als seine sowjetunion an den rändern
immer weiter erodierte schickte
bauwirtschaft panzer in den kaukasus ins
baltikum alte russische autoritäre
reflexe viele tote auch das war
gorbatschow
[Applaus]
im westen gefeiert verklärt in russland
oft verachtet der vorwurf er habe die
sowjetunion verkauft
tausendmal ist mir diese frage bereits
gestellt worden die geschichte wird
eines tages zeigen dass ich alles getan
habe nur eines nicht nämlich mein land
verkauft soll die geschichte eines tages
darüber entscheiden
er habe hat er einmal gesagt nur an die
tür der geschichte geklopft und sie habe
sich aufgetan
[Musik]
sechzehnter juli 1990 ein gipfeltreffen
auf baumstümpfen in strickjacke und
pullover strickjacke und baumstumpf sind
längst im museum ausgestellt es ist ein
historischer moment helmut kohl und
michail gorbatschow machen den weg frei
für die deutsche einheit das wunder vom
kaukasus und immer dabei auf allen fotos
zu sehen direkt hinter gorbatschow der
damalige finanzminister theo waigel
guten abend herr waigel
guten abend ich nehme an sie haben jetzt
auch wieder an diesem moment gedacht wie
haben sie denn gorbatschow erlebt damals
an diesen zwei historischen tagen im
kaukasus
ja das war bewegend weil sich damit die
geschichte deutschlands verändert hat zu
einem so positiven zeitpunkt wie wir es
im vergangenen jahrhundert eigentlich
nicht mehr erwartet hatten ich hatte
zwei jahre zuvor bereits die möglichkeit
ihn kennenzulernen
bei dem dreieinhalbstündigen gespräch
mit franz josef strauß in moskau und zu
dem treffen in aris ist es gekommen weil
helmut kohl in sehr kluger weise immer
seine partner seine gegenüber fragte wo
kommst du her wo bist du geboren
wie war deine kindheit und so kam die
einladung nach stawropol wo er seine
politische karriere begann und dann in
akkus zustande seine nähere heimat und
dort vollzog sich eine wende der
geschichte die dann das letzte jahrzehnt
des vergangenen jahrhunderts zum besten
der deutschen geschichte machte sie
haben sich bis heute umgeben mit fotos
von von michael gorbatschow und sich
selbst die sie beide gemeinsam zeigen
mit widmungen darauf von denen sie sagen
die bedeuten ihnen mehr als alle
auszeichnungen und orden wieso
ja es ist wahr und vor zwei jahren haben
wir noch einen brief geschrieben als ich
ihm in einer rede in der basilika von
ottobeuren für das dankte was 30 jahre
zuvor geschehen war und sein letzter
satz lautete ich halte deine hand theo
ganz fest ich hoffe wir sehen uns wieder
und das ist einer der wichtigsten briefe
die ich in meinem leben erhalten habe
und auf den bildern zeigt er auch mit
unterschrift das an die gemeinsame zeit
dankbar zurückblickt obwohl er mich mal
beim achtzigsten geburtstag von helmut
kohl also mich erblickt er eine
geizkragen nannte weil er meinte ich
hätte zu wenig geld bezahlt für die
deutsche einheit damals als
finanzminister
sie haben ihn einen helden der
geschichte genannt aber wenn man sie
jetzt zuhört herr waigel dann haben sie
mit michael gorbatschow auch einen
freund verloren oder
ja in der tat ein politischer und ein
persönlicher freund als er gestützt
wurde und
den kriebel verlassen musste traf ich
ihn kurz danach
verhärmt
einsam traurig an und ich sagte ihm
damals in diesen schweren tagen haben
viele dort viele menschen in deutschland
für um sie gebangt und für sie gebetet
und dann die tränen über das gesicht das
sind momente
großartige und traurige die mich wie
diesen großartigen mann verbinden
wenn deutsche und russen
zusammenarbeiten hatte er 1987 gesagt
dann gibt es ordnung in europa jetzt
sind wir ja von diesem zustand aktuell
ferner denn je
ja das war in der tat
seine idee des friedens aufeinander
zuzugehen verschiedene systeme zu
akzeptieren die souveränität der völker
anzuerkennen und er meinte dass in einer
solchen situation
russland eine wichtige rolle in europa
spielen könne und er hat eines erkannt
vor allen anderen es macht keinen sinn
ein westdeutschland zu haben mit dem man
in gegnerschaft gegenüber steht und in
ostdeutschland
das kommunistisch regiert ist und von
den subventionen der sowjetunion
abhängig ist und seine großartige idee
die er gegen seine berater und gegen die
mehrheit des politbüros durchsetzte war
die zusammenarbeit zwischen der
sowjetunion und dem wiedervereinigten
deutschland bringt für alle
beteiligten mehr vorteile als der
vorhergehende zustand er war gewann als
finanzminister damals dabei sie haben
hatte die anekdote erzählt von
gorbatschow der sie geizt kragen genannt
hat jetzt hat deutschland aber
gorbatschow ja auch massiv unterstützt
mit vielen milliarden mark haben wir
denn danach im verhältnis zu russland
und den russen den richtigen weg gewählt
ich glaube ja wobei auch bei dem
beitritt der nato staaten aus osteuropa
immer die zusammenarbeit mit russland
das gespräch und auch abkommen über
rüstungs begrenzung eine rolle spielte
wir haben in der tat damals mutig
gehandelt wir haben ihm im frühjahr
einen ungebundene finanzkredite zur
verfügung gestellt die in russland aber
zurückzahlte und wir haben für den abzug
der russischen truppen es waren immerhin
vier bis 500.000 russische sowjetische
soldaten in deutschland
zusammen mit den bediensteten und
familienangehörigen waren wir es
zeitweilig über eine million
und es ist gelungen für 12 milliarden
d-mark den gesamten rückzug der
russischen truppen und ihrer waffen man
denke an die ss 20 raketen die
unmittelbar auf deutschland gerichtet
waren zu erreichen ich glaube
das war eine der wichtigsten und
bewegendsten vereinbarungen die wir
treffen konnten
theo waigel und seine erinnerungen an
michael gorbatschow einen freund hat
sich dank für das gespräch
gerne
das gespräch haben wir heute abend
aufgezeichnet eine ausführliche
dokumentation über das leben von einem
der im grunde zwei leben hatte in der
zdf mediathek zu finden
und damit sind wir in der deutschen
politik für die der russische krieg
gegen die ukraine ja jeden tag neue
herausforderungen bereit hält es gehört
zum politischen handwerkszeug bei
wichtigen terminen ein zwei schlagworte
zu setzen die sich dann möglichst bei
allen bürgerinnen und bürgern ein
brennen sollen das ist immer dann
besonders auffällig wenn auch kaum
wirklich greifbare ergebnisse zu
verkünden sind heute sollten sie darauf
das wort wuchtig achten wie in wuchtiges
entlastungspaket von abschluss- und
ergebnissen der klausurtagung der
bundesregierung berichtet lars borg
da treten drei männer bereits am mittag
vor die kameras die erst einmal einen
eindruck zerstreuen müssen der sich in
den letzten tagen erhärtet hatte der
eindruck dass sie zerstritten sein und
mehr gegeneinander als miteinander
arbeiten würden manches bekenntnis
allerdings wird ein wenig dick
aufgetragen wie gut es ist dass olaf
scholz dieser regierung führt mit seiner
erfahrung mit seiner umsicht mit seiner
ruhe das zeigt sich daran dass wir
ergebnisse miteinander erreichen wie man
auch hier meseberg
sinnlich erfahren konnte die klausur als
sinnliche erfahrung deren ergebnisse
allerdings kaum sichtbar werden
inhaltlich bleiben viele fragen offen
zwar können sich die koalitionäre eine
nachfolge des neuen euro tickets
vorstellen doch wann und wie teuer keine
antwort wer wird direkt leistungen
erhalten wir nicht bleibt offen so gut
wie nichts dringt durch zum geplanten
dritten entlastungspaket an dem arbeiten
wir übrigens sehr vertraulich sehr
sorgfältig in der regierung eine engere
kopplung mit all unseren freundinnen und
freunden in der regierungskoalition dass
sie davon nicht so viel mitbekommen
haben macht mich professionell stolz und
so bleiben neben dem stolz des kanzlers
hauptsächlich formelhafte ankündigungen
wuchtig soll das entlastungspaket seien
sozial ausgewogen und finanzierbar gehe
ich davon aus dass wir in einem
einstelligen milliarden-euro-bereich
noch über spielräume verfügen werden im
nächsten jahr wir von einem
zweistelligen milliardenbetrag ausgehen
können an entlastung für die bürgerinnen
und bürger obwohl der russische
staatskonzern gazprom erneut seine
lieferungen durch die nordsee pipeline
nord stream 1 für angebliche
wartungsarbeiten und verbrochen hat gibt
es an anderer stelle entwarnung die
deutschen gasspeicher sind bereits 85
prozent befüllt weil wir so früh
angefangen haben haben wir antworten und
haben ein fortschritt erzielt der aus
uns jetzt erlaubt gerüstet in den winter
zu gehen die zwischen den
koalitionsparteien umstrittene über
gewinn steuer ist offenbar vom tisch
stattdessen soll wohl der preis von
gaskraftwerken produzierten strom vom
restlichen strommarkt abgekoppelt werden
europaweit und sehr schnell also das
billig strom produziert wird und man von
der tatsache profitiert dass es eine
kleine begrenzte menge von kraftwerken
gibt die mit gas strom produzieren und
dass wir das nicht einfach auf sich
beruhen lassen können das ist
offensichtlich ein koalitionsausschuss
soll in den kommenden tagen beschließen
wie das dritte entlastungspaket aussehen
soll dann wird sich beweisen
die ampel tatsächlich auch weiterhin zu
kompromissen fähig ist
trauer heute noch um einen anderen
eigensinnigen und eigenwilligen polit
menschen der dieses land hier sehr
geprägt hat hanna der grünen politiker
hans christian ströbele ist im alter von
83 jahren gestorben
er verteidigte raf terroristen hat die
grünen mit begründet und war
langjähriger bundestagsabgeordneter mit
klarer motivation
ich will die welt verändern die
gesellschaft das will ich schon seit den
sechziger jahren
das fahrrad war sein markenzeichen er
war links kämpfte beharrlich für
bürgerrechte und war durchaus unbequem
auch für seine partei als erster grüner
holte ströbele 2002 ein direktmandat für
den bundestag
21 jahre lang war dort insgesamt
abgeordneter erst 2017 stieg ströbele
aus der aktiven politik aus
und zur erinnerung an hans christian
ströbele zeigt das zdf die doku die 68er
wir waren die zukunft heute nacht um 1
uhr 30
und nun zu mehreren entscheidungen des
bundeskabinetts die korona regeln für
unternehmen sollen ab herbst weniger
streng ausfallen als bisher geplant so
sollen betriebe nun doch nicht dazu
verpflichtet werden ihren beschäftigten
die arbeit aus dem home office zu
ermöglichen gleiches gilt für das
angebot von corona tests außerdem will
die bundesregierung ab anfang 2003 und
20 bei vorgezogenen
altersrenten die
hinzuverdienstgrenzen streichen für
erwerbsminderungsrentner bleiben die
grenzen nach den plänen bestehen sie
werden aber deutlich erhöht
jahrzehntelang haben bundesregierung und
hinterbliebene des olympia attentats von
1972 über eine entschädigung gestritten
nun eine einigung neben einer
finanziellen entschädigung die nach
zdf-informationen rund 28 millionen euro
beträgt sollen die geschehnisse durch
eine kommission aufgearbeitet werden die
hinterbliebenen wollen nun auch an der
gedenkfeier teilnehmen am 15 september
1972 hatten palästinensische terroristen
bei den olympischen spielen in münchen
elf mitglieder der israelischen
mannschaft getötet zudem kam ein
deutscher polizist ums leben
die russinnen und russen wird es
schwieriger ein visum für die
europäische union zu bekommen mit blick
auf den russischen angriffskrieg auf die
ukraine hat die eu ein abkommen zu
erleichterten visavergabe ausgesetzt
einen generellen einreise stopp soll es
also nicht geben außenministerin
bernburg erklärte das visum helfe
menschen die russland verlassen wollen
wie journalisten oder studenten
der krieg in der ukraine ist auch thema
bei der vollversammlung des ökumenischen
rates der kirchen in karlsruhe eine art
welttreffen christlicher kirchen und
glaubensgemeinschaften
zur eröffnung kritisierte
bundespräsident steinmeier die russisch
orthodoxe kirche scharf ihre führer
unterstützten den angriffskrieg
russlands gegen die ukraine und führten
so ihre gläubigen auf einen pfad
geradezu glaubens feindlichen
blasphemischen
die expertinnen und experten der
internationalen atomenergiebehörde
bewegen sich immer in heiklen thema
politisch sowieso ihre aktuelle mission
dürfte aber die schwierigste sein und
auch die persönlich gefährlichste zum
ersten mal überhaupt in der geschichte
der zivilen nukleartechnik steht ein
atomkraftwerk im zentrum eines krieges
wird selbst beschossen von den
internationalen inspektoren erhofft sich
die welt jetzt mehr kontrolle und mehr
sicherheit und gleichzeitig dass das
kaum zu schaffen sein wird faurecia
ukraine hatte vor dem krieg über 10.000
mitarbeiter es ist das größte
kernkraftwerk europas und das
gefährlichste einer hebestreit ist dort
die atominspektoren haben ist eigentlich
am nachmittag erreichen sie ihr letztes
etappenziel eine unterkunft in der stadt
borussia die immer noch eineinhalb
autostunden entfernt licht vom
gleichnamigen atomkraft werden hier ist
für heute endstation einer der wohl
wichtigsten aufgaben der internationalen
atomenergiebehörde
die mission soll einen nuklearen unfall
verhindern und den weiteren betrieb
dieses wichtigen und größten
atomkraftwerks ganz europas ganz europas
nicht nur der ukraine sicherstellen
seit russische truppen das kraftwerk
besetzt haben ist die anlage auch immer
wieder beschossen worden russen und
ukrainer bezichtigen sich gegenseitig
europa in nukleare geiselhaft zu nehmen
die beschäftigten haben keinen zutritt
mehr zu bestimmten bereichen deshalb
solle die inspektoren prüfen ob die
russen geräte oder gar strahlendes
material entwendet haben
es ist sehr wichtig dass unter den
iaea-inspektoren auch sechs spezialisten
sind die überblick haben über den
bestand an nuklearem material der anlage
das wird eigentlich online überwacht
aber man muss vor ort prüfen ob davon
etwas verschwunden
gleiches gilt für westliche technologie
mit der die anlage modernisiert wurde
und für die ein exportverbot nach
russland besteht bei der mission der
atominspektoren geht es also auch um den
verdacht illegalen technologietransfers
vielleicht sogar um den schmuggel
nuklearen material ist die bevölkerung
und um das kraftwerk oft auf ein ende
der kämpfe
wir wünschen uns dass auch über eine
entmilitarisierung
sensibler teile des kraftwerks
gesprochen wird und man nicht noch mehr
kriegsgerät dahin bringt und die gegend
am ende ein schlachtfeld wird
eine sensible mission also für direktor
raphael gross und sein team während sie
ihre gepanzerten autos für den weg in
die russische zone vorbereiten führt
grossi bis zuletzt verhandlungen mit den
russen
wir arbeiten an den letzten details das
ist alles wirklich sehr kompliziert
die mission wird stand deshalb bin ich
hier und ich werde nicht gehen bis wir
am start sind
wenn sie morgen durchs niemandsland in
die russisch besetzte zone fahren
passieren sie stumme zeugen schweren
beschusses wäre auch heute nicht
aufhörte
ich weiß das ist nicht einfach zu
verkraften was diese welt aktuell tag
für tag für uns bereithält wobei es da
ja nicht um eine schicksalshafte laune
des planeten geht sondern um unser
eigenes tun und deshalb kann uns das
nicht davon abhalten jetzt dringend nach
pakistan zu schauen wo der
regierungschef sich flehentlich an die
welt wendet und sagt die bedrohung durch
den klimawandel ist real mächtig und sie
start uns ins gesicht er meint die
verheerenden überschwemmungen in seinem
land über 33 millionen menschen die
direkt betroffen sind kaum fassbare
zahlen der blick auf die schicksale dort
jetzt von normen odenthal
nur ein flecken fels ragt noch aus den
tosenden fluten der hubschrauber ist die
rettung in letzter sekunde 1 von
unzähligen dramen viele enten nicht so
glücklich
es ist nicht mehr dasselbe land pakistan
vor und nach der flut aus der ferne
sieht man das ausmass aus der nähe sieht
man die not die witwe bibi nokia watet
durch die braune brühe wo gestern noch
ihr haus stand nur trümmer sind
geblieben baby sucht nach allem was noch
brauchbar ist doch da ist fast nichts
was soll ich tun ich kann nur warnen wo
sollen wir hin wir sind hilflos ich habe
fieber wir haben nichts zu essen mein
sohn ist krank ich muss mich um meine
kinder und um meine enkel kümmern wir
haben kein dach mehr über dem kopf
der alte ochsenkarren gibt etwas schutz
am straßenrand es ist unfassbar was so
viele jetzt aushalten müssen hier war
kein fluss hier war der markt von wachen
doch das wasser das unablässig von den
bergen schießt reist wunde um wunde in
die stadt seit 78 jahren lebt bahadur
hier und sitzt nun fassungslos in einer
trümmerfeld
wir haben befürchtet dass es schlimm
wird aber dann kam die flut so plötzlich
wir konnten nur noch raus es ging um
unser leben die häuser sind alle
eingestürzt unser ganzes hab und gut ist
weggespült
waghalsig müssen sie sein um zu retten
was noch zu retten ist es ist auch ein
kampf gegen die zeit weil es wieder
regnen soll weiter regnen soll der
monsun will kein ende nehmen
ein albtraum das wirft uns zurück um 20
jahre so lange wird es dauern bis wir
uns stabilisiert haben wir müssen unser
haus wieder aufbauen wir müssen unser
geschäft wieder aufbauen das braucht
eine ewig
schäden in milliarden höhe im ganzen
land wenn sich das überhaupt beziffern
lässt denn menschenleben sind
unwiederbringlich unter den fast 1200
toten sind 400 kinder die zahlen steigen
krankheiten wie cholera und ruhe breiten
sich aus in notunterkünften die im
wahrsten sinne des wortes welche sind
sie haben uns in dieser schule
untergebracht aber wir bekommen nichts
zu essen es wäre besser wir wären gleich
in den fluten ertrunken wir haben kleine
kinder hier ist es überall dreckig und
es gibt viele moskitos es ist schlimm
der staat ist überfordert kein wunder
beim ausmaß der katastrophe aber viele
fühlen sich von ihrer regierung im stich
gelassen
internationale hilfe läuft an sie wird
dringend benötigt
lasst uns die menschen pakistans
solidarisch in ihrer not unterstützen
lasst uns nicht weiter schlafwandeln
richtung zerstörung unseres planeten
durch den klimawandel heute trifft es
pakistan morgen kann es ihr land treffen
an morgen können sie in pakistan kommen
denken sie müssen heute über leben und
sie können helfen wenn sie mögen und
zwar über das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe
hier ist die bankverbindung bahn.de 65
104 106 100 104 106 100 das stichwort
zdf nothilfe pakistan
und jetzt hier in der sendung number du
hanna die bundesagentur für arbeit hat
heute die aktuellen arbeitslosenzahlen
veröffentlicht und die zeigen trotz
aller krisen trotz gasknappheit
explodierende energiekosten und
lieferketten problemen der deutsche
arbeitsmarkt präsentiert sich ziemlich
robust valerie haller in frankfurt woran
liegt das genau naja also diese alte
faustregel schwache konjunktur
arbeitslosigkeit drauf die gilt schon
seit einigen jahren nicht mehr ja und
der ein grund ist einfach des
fachkräftemangels selbst in
wirtschaftlich schwierigen zeiten halten
firmen ihre mitarbeiter weil sie sorge
haben keine neuen zu finden wenn es
wieder bergauf geht der arbeitsmarkt hat
sich also von der wirtschaftlichen
entwicklung weitgehend entkoppelt
trainiere für andrea nahles die
ehemalige spd vorsitzende und
bundesministerin jetzt chefin der
bundesagentur für arbeit kein
frühindikator deute auf eine trendwende
hin die nachfrage nach personal sei groß
die zahl der erwerbstätigen gestiegen
allen krisen zum trotz gab es im august
zweieinhalb millionen arbeitslose das
sind im vergleich zum vorjahr
31.000 weniger gegenüber dem vormonat
stieg die zahl jedoch um
77.000 die arbeitslosenquote lag bei 5,6
prozent
dass es im august mehr arbeitslose gab
als im monat zuvor geht hauptsächlich
auf die erfassung ukrainischer
geflüchteter in jobcentern zurück und
darauf dass im sommer viele ausbildungen
enden die energiekrise hat also bisher
kaum einfluss auf den arbeitsmarkt laut
bundesagentur für arbeit lag sich aber
wieder mehr betriebe zur kurzarbeit
beraten und das deutet schon darauf hin
dass unternehmen mit blick auf die
krisen behaftete zeit inzwischen
skeptischer geworden sind vielen dank
ballerina frankfurt
zu den lottozahlen an diesem mittwoch
die lauten 15 11 18 24 37 superzahl 7
alle angaben wie immer ohne gewähr
und das war sie unsere welt an diesem
letzten augusttag herzlichen dank für
ihr interesse und bis morgen dann
beginnt übrigens in der ukraine wieder
für alle kids die schule unterricht im
bunker das ist ein thema gleich nach uns
hier im auslandsjournal und die nächsten
nachrichten gibt's gegen 0 uhr 30 in
unserem heute journal update mit gundula
gause von unserem gesamten team hier
angenehm haben
[Musik]
guten abend in den nächsten tagen wird
dieses tief hier vor frankreich für uns
interessant denn das schaufel aus
südwesteuropa noch mal höhere
temperaturen heran und so zieht sich die
kühle luft hier weiter richtung
skandinavien zurück heute nacht sinken
die temperaturen auf 14 bis 8 grad
zwischen den bayrischen wald und am
alpenrand fällt noch regen es gibt auch
einzelne schauer an der ostsee oder an
der rusel an diesem wetter erinnert sich
morgen über tag wenig sonne und wolken
wechseln sich ab an den alpen lassen die
regenfälle nach und es gibt noch einige
schauer an der ostsee die temperaturen
liegen morgens zwischen 19 grad an den
alpen und bis zu 27 grad am rhein und in
den nächsten tagen gibt es dann schauer
und gewitter vor allen dingen im
südwesten und süden in norddeutschland
aber bleibt ist trocken da liegen die
temperaturen dann so bei 20 bis 29 grad
und es wird ja sogar noch mal wärmer und
das sehen sie hier am temperatur film
für deutschland nämlich bis montag
steigen die temperaturen hier am
oberrhein noch mal bis 30 grad und wenn
sie sich jetzt fragen ob das immer so
weiter geht schauen wir gemeinsam auf
den trend für freiburg im breisgau oder
sehen sie nämlich nach montag sinken die
temperaturen auf herzlich herres niveau
zwischen 20 und 25 grad und dann fällt
auch mal häufiger wieder etwas regen
guten abend